how are you doing today
i'm good how are you good to see you
nice to see you uh i want to jump
backwards in time to start this
interview off
what do you remember about making nacho
libre
why do i i actually remember eating a
lot with jack black
going to the market and um
because i was in an undress i could i
didn't care about
you know if i gain weight i couldn't
it didn't matter so i remember that and
it was i
i just remembered oaxaca i just remember
the city we were shooting there for two
months and it was beautiful
so um it was a wonderful experience to
be honest
one of the best experiences i've had
yeah i can't imagine how people treated
you if you're wearing that none dress
offset
that's a whole nother it's a whole
another thing uh so i love learning
about the behind the scenes
of the making on of the making of movies
so
what do you think might surprise people
to learn about the making
of this purge film i think it's scary
movies in particular
in particular because you know it's it's
a lot of work and it's very intense and
you're screaming
i think as soon from well that's what
happened in this head as soon as we were
done we were just
joking and dancing and playing and and
it's like nothing seriously
nothing serious of course you know like
we're just trying to
uh kind of balance the intensity and the
screams with fun and with something
light
and with jokes so that's that's mostly
what happens and
it happens in every set but i think it's
funnier in scary sets you know
completely uh yeah one of the things one
of the things about this film is that
you can take it as just a pure fun movie
escapism
but you can also look at this film
there's a lot of subtext to this film
it's talking a lot about what's going on
with immigration
and so many things can you sort of talk
about that aspect of
film yeah that's what i loved about it
uh
that it has a message you know that it
talks about equality
about respecting one another like about
like we at some point like
we there's two kind of families
coming together as a team
where they are completely different and
they would never
being in the same you know in the same
team
if it wasn't for this situation so
that makes it really interesting and um
and and that's one thing and then at the
end yeah it's it
it talks a lot about um immigration and
and racism too
you know 100 one of the other
so i'm also curious this franchise this
is like the fifth movie in the franchise
it's been a tv series what do you think
it is about
the purge uh that that resonates so
strongly with so many people
well i feel like they just you know i
just feel like people
first of all if they you like a concept
people is gonna they're gonna go
back to to revise it and and just to
it's just there's some comfort in us
knowing kind of like
what's gonna happen in a movie you know
what what's the ride you're getting
into so that's one thing and also i feel
the concept
is really is really genius it's like
those 12 hours when you can do whatever
you want
without any um what's what's the word
with that without consequences
consequences that's the word thank you
so i think that
we even if not not me like i'm not gonna
kill someone but like just stealing
something without any consequences or
like
saying something to someone or doing
something or
uh even like riding your car
in a you know in a speed that is not
permitted
without any consequences it's kind of
like very is very alluring
so i just feel like that that makes
people wanted to see it
i completely agree uh before i round to
time with you i
am so curious about this army of the
dead lost the animated series
that you're doing uh what can you tease
people about it have you seen any of it
i haven't seen any of it i actually i
did
i did the voice last year actually this
yeah like it was in the summer of last
year um
but you will see a lot of backstories
from all the characters that you already
know
you know especially from the veterans
from dave from me from omari
you know from vanderholt and from uh
peters and and and and
ella and kate's so you'll you'll know
more about our background how we met
and our relationships before um the
movie starts
so yeah i think i think if you love the
movie
you know you you love the show you love
the animals
is it is it multiple episodes is it like
one movie i'm actually not sure
it's multiple episodes yes got it it's
serious got it i i wasn't 100 sure my
last thing for you
uh what's coming up for you next what
are you getting ready to do
um can't really talk about it but i'm
getting ready to do a comedy
um that i produced and then i wrote
uh in i started shooting at the end of
august
and you wrote this i wrote this yes i
wrote this yeah
do you can you say what the title is i
can't i can't but
uh but yes it's it's it is but the only
thing is for the
subtitle and it's a little bilingual but
it's mostly for
for it's for amazon and and comedy
central and um
from september to december i'll be i'll
be shooting that
ah so i i now realize it's a series
it is a serious yes yeah there's no way
that's just
that's just a movie shoot anyway i'll
stop there
i'm just gonna say congratulations on
this specifically
and thank you so much for giving me your
time no thank you thank you i'm very
glad i talked to you have a great day
you do